really cool all right so it's an
exciting day here in las vegas
mgm resorts is bringing back seven shows
tonight after
months have been closed one of those is
fantasy at the luxor
and joining us this morning is the
show's producer anita mann good morning
to you anita i can't imagine how excited
you guys are
oh my gosh thank you it's really
exciting i'm happy to be here
well we see some of the lovely ladies
behind you i know you guys have a long
day ahead so we're happy you guys are
with us this morning
anita when were you guys given the green
light that you could go back
and reopen
about two weeks ago and it it finally
came true so
we were thinking many many times before
that we were going to open but this was
it for real two weeks ago
oh my goodness so tell me about the last
two weeks that is not a lot of time
it's been a whirlwind i can't believe
it's november 6
today but i just started really
literally building the set
getting the ladies back together and we
did it
so we started this week actually
rehearsing with the ladies on sunday
re-choreographing the show i called in
renee lagler my set designer
he built a set had designed it and
it's been an interesting but a very
exciting week
so from a producing standpoint how much
different will the show be now were you
forced to make a lot of changes
oh yes we um actually sorry this is
falling down
we actually are staying six feet apart
on stage we're allowed to get close to
each other for no more than 15 minutes
and i've kept it down to seven minutes
but we are dancing six feet apart for
the entire show
but it's really spectacular it's a big
looking
production numbers and the stage is
just gorgeous for the dancers and the
audience is all six feet apart
everything is really redone
well it looks absolutely beautiful that
set is incredible
what are some of the other changes that
fans can expect when they go in tonight
well we we're going to have a lot of
changes we have murray saw chuck who's a
wonderful
magician and a very talented
illusionist so we'll be having illusions
in the show
we have some phenomenal new songs
vocalists uh loreen apparel
lorena is just incredible we have new
dance numbers it's just going to be a
big production it's a it's a really
exciting
uh situation it was a challenge but i
think everybody loves it we're just
having a ball this week
well it's so exciting that not only the
show will be back but everyone's getting
back to work too so anita thank you so
much
we look forward to seeing the new
fantasy tonight thank you for being with
us so early
um thank you i really appreciate
your you're asking us about the show
we're excited absolutely
break a leg thank you it's 5 48 now
so let's take a look at all the mgm
resort shows that are reopening tonight
so australian bee gees brad garrett's
comedy club
carrot top david copperfield fantasy as
we just showed you
the jabberwockies and of course thunder
from down under
guys so some really exciting news and a
lot of people getting back to work after
several long months which